>>> WE'RE HERE TODAY WITH FILM
STAR NATALIE PORTMAN.
NOW NATALIE, THE LAST TIME YOU
WERE HERE, I HEARD THINGS GOT A
LITTLE OUT OF CONTROL?
>> YEAH, WELL I WAS GOING
THROUGH A REALLY WEIRD TIME
THEN, BUT I'VE MATURED A LOT.
>> WELL THAT'S GOOD TO HEAR.
WHY DON'T YOU FILL US IN ON WHAT
IT'S LIKE TO BE YOU?
>> OKAY, YOU BISH.
>> I'M SORRY, WHAT?
♪♪♪
♪ YEAH, PORTMAN PORTMAN
PORTMAN PORTMAN PORTMAN
PORTMAN
♪ YOUR HUSBAND AND HIS
FRIENDS RUN OUT TO
PORTMAN
MESSED AROUND AND MADE
THE SAME SONG TWICE
HERE'S THE WORDS NOW WE
GET CONDOLEEZA RICE
XANNIES DISSOLVING IN MY
PINO
MY MAN'S DANCE BUDDY'S
NOT A
BALLERINO ♪
YEAH.
WHAT HAPPEN UP A BURRITO.
THE ONLY THING I SNACK ON
♪ BLACK OUT AND GO
MOTHER
[ BLEEP ] BLACK SWAN♪
♪TURN INTO A FOSTER BOY♪
>> IT SEEMS LIKE YOU'RE
ALMOST
EXACTLY THE SAME, BUT YOU HAVE
DIFFERENT REFERENCES
>> IT SEEMS THE SAME, BUT JUST
UP DATED.
>> DO YOU FIND IT DIFFICULT
JUGGLING THESE KIDS AND MOVIES.
>> JUGGLE THESE NUTS.
♪ I WAS BLAZED OUT, SMOKING, YOU
KNOW I'M A DOCTOR ♪
♪ HELL YEAH I'M POSITIVE, THAT'S
WHAT IS GOING ON I'M BUSTING MY
PREROGATIVES ♪
♪ I GUESS I'M SHOWING MY AGE,
NOW BEND OVER AND SPREAD THEM
BECAUSE YOU'RE ABOUT TO GET
[ BLEEP ] ♪
I GUESS I'M SHOWING MAY AGE, NOW
TURN OVER AND SPREAD THEM
BECAUSE YOU'RE ABOUT TO GET
[ BLEEP ]
>> HAVE YOU SEEN THE NEW "STAR
WARS" MOVIES?
>> NO.
>> THEY'RE MUCH BETTER THAN ♪
--
♪ SAY SOMETHING ABOUT IT MOTHER
[ BLEEP ], WHILE I -- ON YOUR
FACE AND TAKE A [ BLEEP ] ♪
♪ ON 17 WHILE I SIT ON YOUR FACE
AND TAKE A ♪
♪ OH NATALIE, IT'S BEEN SEVEN
♪ BABY, HE CRIES HIMSELF TO
SLEEP EVERY NIGHT ♪
♪ THAT LITTLE [ BLEEP ] AIN'T
MINE ♪
♪ OH NATALIE, IT'S BEEN 12 LONG
YEARS, YOU'RE A MESS, CARL.
>> OKAY WELL, THAT'S ALL THE
TIME WE HAVE.
NATALIE, ONE LAST QUESTION.
DO YOU THINK THOSE TIMES THE
TIMES UP THING HAVE THE IMPACT
YOU WERE HOPING FOR?
>> HOW'S THAT FOR IMPACT?
>> ACTUALLY --
>> NO MORE QUESTIONS.
♪♪♪